jeff bezos did one of the most likable
things or maybe the only likable thing
i've ever seen him do outside of get me
[ __ ] within 24 hours whenever i need it
and uh he did you see what happened yeah
yeah yeah it was just amazing so his new
wife is like cheesed up talking to
leonardo checking them out i mean it's
disrespectful and i think leo is like on
an apple box or something he's like
sitting away
he just looks so tiny and like his
girl's like looking up to him yeah and
then looks them up and down if her
titties are pointed at you that's a
problem like she was wild she was being
disrespectful like that was super wild
and um
and and what's his face the next day
jeff bezos uh posted a picture i think
on twitter yeah and uh what did it say
said leo uh we need to have a word or
something like that basically said leo
let me show you something actually that
was funny wording yeah you know he
literally goes yo leo let me show you
something like that's our line
that was our show
all right jeff and then it's just him on
a uh like on a cliff on a sign that says
like caution steep cliff might fall off
some [ __ ] yeah
so he yeah he's gonna set the demons out
for leo though yeah and he strategically
placed it in front of his upper body
except for his arms put on the things
that look mad bro
he looks like way better shape than he
is this guy thought it through it was a
photo op he went with his amazon number
two and was like let's figure this [ __ ]
out i'm [ __ ] getting embarrassed out
here in these streets now um what do you
do in that situation where your girls
like head over heels in love with
another man it depends on who if it's
leo i'm probably going to be checking
him out with her yeah so i wouldn't even
notice leo's a tough one because it's
like yeah leo he wasn't even trying
that's the he wasn't being flirty he
seemed the opposite he was extremely
concerned no that made it worse that
made it more embarrassing but she knows
like leo got an age limit that's true
yeah he thought that was his mom yeah
like shorty he's probably around like 40
or something like that or like 50. and
like leo's not doing that yeah he was
doing 25. yeah 25 tops yeah you know
yeah there's no way so leo's probably
confused about this whole situation like
what the [ __ ] is going on here like why
is this girl looking at me like this in
front of jeff bezos he's probably trying
to talk to jeff bezos yeah
probably not talking to these 50 year
old women yeah definitely not dude the
oldest woman he's ever been with is
probably kate winslet in titanic yeah
he's probably like
this i really gotta act here never again
that was it he made out with kate
winslet in the back of an old model t
and he's never hooked up with a girl
that old ever again you know talk about
how this guy got such a problem with the
icebergs melting but it wasn't for an
iceberg you wouldn't have a career yeah
that's a good point
am i going to talk about that a hot ass
take yeah that's why he's concerned
about them melting he's like yo we gotta
bring these [ __ ] back titanic
too yo
you're right
you're right that's a great [ __ ]
point or maybe he doesn't want to melt
so there won't be a replacement
oh he doesn't want someone else to take
he's killing the artist you got to kill
the artist
but yeah i think this kind of just
confirms like
basically do you want wealth or fame
like that old debate
if you could get one or the other like
fame i'm assuming plus like charm
personality or just pure wealth yeah
you might want fame dog but leo
you want what you don't have
because i don't think that leo is more
famous than jeff bezos
i mean as far as like if you see them
both walking on the street i think more
people recognize leo
i don't think people know what bezos
looks like as much as they use his [ __ ]
every day
man i i think it's i think it's tricky
though okay don't you think it's close
probably closer than i'm thinking
because my initial thought is a hundred
people are going to recognize leo out of
a hundred and thirty you're gonna write
if i see leo i like i'm probably being
yeah i'm excited to see liv
around those actors like her ex-husband
is patrick weitzel who like runs wme
like
has ben affleck as a client christian
bale she's been around these people yeah
but this is my dog this is all right i'm
in the room i'm glowed up let me just
have this
leo
look to me in a certain way this is
different it's not ben affleck
certainly by affleck so you think she
was just trying to be charming you think
she was trying to be flirty and fun
makes you too old bro she wants to flex
if like she could get some attention for
sure how old is she
i'm gonna look at it because here's the
thing leo's 50. yeah but so it's not
like
like it's one thing when you're playing
mom she's 51. she's 51 and leo is what
50. so it's one thing when you're
playing mom and you're flirting with the
younger man he's
he's 46. okay so if you're playing mom
and flirting with a younger man that's
kind of fun like if meryl streep comes
up to me and she starts flirting with me
and saying some wild [ __ ] it's adorable
she could say the wildest [ __ ] in the
entire world to me just like an old man
like can like can say that to a girl in
her like 30s or 40s and it's kind of
like charming like he could be like old
and creepy but it's kind of like funny
yeah less less charmer than a woman fair
enough way less sorry but when it worked
i think you're thinking of when your dad
doesn't he's not creepy at all he says
pretty mild things but yeah like uh no
no no i mean like literally like the
grandpa in the movie who's like oh
yeah yeah yeah no that is kind of funny
it is kind of funny like a grandpa at a
diner saying things to the waitress and
the waitress like oh harold shut up
right like because they know it's so
ridiculous and it could never happen
right you know or like the nerd
character hitting on the hot chick he
can say whatever because it's absurd
it's never gonna happen right the
insulting thing is she might be
operating with him as if it could never
happen it's ridiculous
but they're within the [ __ ] range yeah
five years five years i mean most people
are in leo's [ __ ] range
oh no most people should be yeah yeah
yeah most people should be in leo's [ __ ]
range right but like that's an
interesting perspective like i don't
this is funny she's probably looking at
a situation like i'm 51 but i'm bad i
got the richest man on the planet
to leave wifey
yeah like
i got the richest man on the planet to
give away half his [ __ ] for this [ __ ]
yeah got with me while he was with her
like this is the most fire [ __ ] ever
yeah he gave up half
of the wealth of the richest person on
the planet never in history that ever
happened
that's how fire the [ __ ] is right so
she's probably looking at leo like if i
want it i'll get it yeah and leo's
looking at her like grandma
let me talk to bezos for a second what
the [ __ ] is going on like they don't
understand what's happening leo's trying
to steal jeff from her yeah yeah i mean
neil would rather be a jeff they both
want to solve the [ __ ] climate crisis
or whatever the hell is going on yeah
even though they're both contributing to
it absolutely 100 percent nobody's
destroying the environment more than
bezos oh okay right it's not recyclable
on boxes that come to your house
well i think they are they are you can't
recycle boxes yeah you can just keep on
spinning that [ __ ] it's legit the number
one [ __ ] to recycle this car yeah i
never had anything that was recycled out
of boxes yeah yeah what you have is
recycled cardboard a lot of boxes a lot
more boxes they make boxes out of boxes
that's that's almost how they can't make
boxes out of boxes what do you think
they make boxes out of tree
they make it out of tree bruh
why do you think there's no amazon
because of amazon dog
i mean come on guys this is basic
information this is basic knowledge you
can't make boxes out of recycled boxes
you already know you didn't name a
company after the [ __ ] he'd taken out
completely no from
[Applause]
yeah you gotta kill the first amazon
control the supply hundred percent smart
hundred percent man this guy's serious
have you all googled it yet yeah i think
there's a lot of things that you've used
as we cannot make boxes out of recycled
boxes yeah it's confirmed most boxes in
the united states or no 65 boxes are
made from partially recycled boxes at
least oh partially that's 61 as partial
are partially recycled boxes and i think
at least one is probably fully recycled
nope
the box is recyclable even if it's
partially recycled nope once it's open
and put together it can't be used as a
box anymore the sixth most recycled item
ever is corrugated cardboard
what corrugated cardboard
boxes yeah and newspaper is made of
recycle boxes
and uh jeff bezos's wife is a recycled
box
that's interesting
you out here king
you